hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game that comes as a suggestion
from luke meyer uh thank you for such a
nice suggestion it's a game from the
soviet team championship the seventh
soviet team championship uh it was
played in 1960 and it was played in
october so of course uh uh the tigran
former world champion tina petrosian was
uh not a world champion yet uh this like
i said was played in october and in may
we had the uh tal versus botwinnik match
so of course you guys know who the world
champion was uh at the time this game
was played but still petrossian uh
definitely a formidable opponent for
anyone and levon a we've mentioned him
on the channel if you guys remember
during the uh bobby fischer saga uh he
was one of boris posky's seconds during
his uh 1972 match against bobby fisher
alongside nikolai krogeos and uh and
effing geller uh he also helped out but
there were the
the three three of them were like steady
seconds but he also had help from other
players like karpov himself and so on uh
but okay getting back to this game uh it
was suggested as it features a a
wonderful uh queen sacrifice that
happens uh not uh i believe not because
um tigran misses it but because he's
hoping that uh
lebone will miss it as it is the only
chance to save the game so let's check
it out and see as it features a very
exciting opening also uh so here we have
d4 uh by level uh knight to f6 c4 and c5
going for the benoni defense and we have
d5 and now uh well nowadays b5 the banco
gambit and the e6 the so-called modern
line are what you will pretty much see
every time but here we have e5 okay this
is also quite popular but not nearly as
popular as the two lines that we've
mentioned it is the czech variation of
the banoni and it is uh
very very different in in terms of
playing style not as crazy and uh tigran
uh well he he really likes uh safe
positions uh
not that you would play this if you
enjoy safe positions but it's much much
safer than those i believe uh he maybe
underestimated
on a a little bit as he was only an
international master at the time this
game was played so who knows what uh uh
made made him go for this opening choice
but okay knight to c3 we have d6 and now
pawn to e4 and here g6 just preparing
the fiance to the uh the bishop uh it's
uh not the maybe the the safest approach
for for for black but um
more of something that you would use if
you were really an attack
attacking player for example you did
polgar used this to defeat the tien
backroad in 1999 uh so you know
it's uh it it would uh be a a an
interesting choice if you are you know
an attacking player but so i think it's
very interesting that tigran uses this
with f3 and knight beat d7 and it is now
as of move six that this position has
never been repeated again we have bishop
to e3 and now pawn to a6 we have knights
to h3 shifting the knight over to f2 and
now rook to b8 preparing to strike on
the queen side would be fine with a4
guarding the b5 square and now just
brush up the g7 we have queen to d2
preparing to trade off the dark square
bishops and now just queen to a5
and here uh we have knight to f2 you
could also play g4 here
positionally this would be better as uh
black wants to put this knight on h5 so
you you should prevent this uh and then
continue with your plan of knight uh
knight to f2 but okay knight to f2
knights the h5 now by tigran and rook to
a3 now the rook will be uh
it can be shifted over to the king side
if the position opens up also you can
put the rook to b3 if needed
we have castles and not knight to d3 uh
and here we have bishop to f6 you could
also strike right away with f5 uh but
tigran uh being tigran he just
re-maneuvers the bishop over to e7 this
will make the position uh a bit safer
and then he's going to strike with f5 so
here at bishop to e2 nicely continuing
development bishop to e7 and now finally
we have castle's king side uh pawn to f5
uh striking here against the center and
now e captures an f5 g captures an f5
and now pawn to f4 uh really weakening
uh tiganon's sentry as he does control a
lot of central squares here knight to g7
uh and now f captures an e5 d captures
on e5 and now bishop to h6 so winning a
lot of a lot of space here queen back to
c7 the queen helping out with with the
defense you have to re-maneuver the
queen to uh
to the center of the board and now g4
opening up the position uh f captures on
g4 and now we have rook captures on f8
you could also uh postpone trading just
knights to e4 maybe first but okay rook
captures we have knight captures and now
knight to e4 putting pressure on this d6
square so for the moment that the knight
is blocking your queen but the knight
will move and then tigran will have to
really worry about this d6 push so
bishop to f5 and now knight d to f2
defending the knight but also now
putting pressure on that d6 square so
knight to e8 guarding the square and
then now comes the bishop captures on g4
just grabbing a pawn here bishop to g6
and now rook to g3 so you can see that
with all of these pieces in front of the
black king with the queen having access
to the king side
it is very very unlikely that tigran
will save the game here but he is the
one of the greatest masters of defense
that ever played uh so anything is
possible king the h8 moving the king
away from the g file now comes bishop to
g5 just offering a trade they're trying
to activate the queen
knights the d6 uh attacking this knight
and the knight captures on d6 and now if
you capture with the knight then you
allow bishop to f6 check maybe
uh giving white a bit too much so
instead we have queen captures on v6
bishop captures an e7 queen captures and
now uh grabbing more space with pawn to
d6 this pawn is also a pass pawn so a
promotion is is very close uh we have
queen to f6 and now queen to d5
rook to f3 was a way to really improve
the game a bit further but
now if if tigran plays it well he could
even defend this position
but he misses it uh the idea is that uh
for example if you play rook to d8 and
now it's very hard for white to defend
uh because how do you defend this pawn
of course rook to f3 saves the pawn
you're gonna move the queen and now
you're gonna play queen captures on c5
and the game continues maybe black can
survive this e4 you have a nice pass
pawn that's defended on e4 you're
attacking the rook the queen can enter
the game so it's possible let's say rook
to b3 would put pressure on the b7 pawn
uh white will always be better but this
was the best way to save the game uh
tigran probably decided that this pawn
will be a weakness at some point and he
pushes it to b6 also helps out with the
defense of the c5 pawn and now if white
doesn't have an instant win then he can
uh he he can play rook to d8 next
however knight to d3
and that's a problem how do you how do
you counter this move uh if you if you
just eliminate the knight for example
bishop captures then uh something uh
terrible happens but i don't want to
spoil it because that's the exact thing
that uh happened in the game already uh
tigram play rook to d8 and now comes
pawn to d7 uh interestingly this is the
only move that wins the game for white
because if you don't uh do this then the
pawn will just fall and there is no
better move you can make so pawn to d7
and now finally uh we have bishop
captures on d3 whatever tigran plays he
here his position is completely lost but
by playing bishop captures on d3 he
allows levonate to end the game in great
style so feel free to pause the video
and try to find this spectacular idea
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting the
symmetry uh and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is queen
to g8 we can also do it in slow motion
because it's beautiful there we have it
queen to g8 with check and there is no
other move that black can make other
than king captures but of course when
tigran saw this it was in this position
on move 33 that he resigned to the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
uh so i don't think tigran missed it i
think that as there's no other way to
play this that he just decided that it
was maybe the best chance or maybe he
even missed it i mean uh crazier things
have happened in chess like you know
people just missing mate in one or stuff
like that but yeah here of course you
resign as after king captures and bishop
to e6 this is not a double check and
that there is only one square for the
king uh king to h8 and not rook to g8
will be checkmate so of course after
this uh queen the g8 check move uh
tigran resigned and a wonderful victory
uh by leibniz against the future world
champion tigran petrossian
uh who will uh win the title in some uh
three years after after this game was
played
uh
so yeah really really really crazy stuff
not another three years
this was in 1960
uh tigran won in uh 67 i believe but i
can i can also check i don't want to
trick you guys let me just check real
quickly
uh
let me just check real quickly
oh no uh fro from 19 uh from 1963 to
1969 yeah i don't know what i was
thinking
tal uh tal won in uh 1960 then uh but we
nick won it back and then in 1963 uh of
course petrossian won it uh uh
from botvinnik who who uh had it for for
like the third time he first lost at the
uh to todd and he lost the dismissal of
and then he finally lost at the
petrossian i have been covering too many
and modern games i have to brush up on
my my chess history it would seem uh but
yeah once again i hope you guys enjoyed
it and uh
we do have some news regarding the world
church championship match between uh
magnus carlsen and yanni pognishi it
seems that fiji never gave carlson the
deadline that he has to give his reply
until the 20th of this month of of july
uh that that
isn't really the case that he can take
uh
more time as
they have to present some other things
as well as but it seems that magnus will
not play and unless they change the the
format so if uh fiji suggests that
magnus should play uh in the exact same
format that they've been using so far
it would seem that magnus will not play
but
these are all just news going around it
doesn't uh necessarily make it true so
as soon as i know something uh real
once we have something tangible i will
of course inform you guys uh so yeah
once again i really hope you guys
enjoyed it brilliant victory by uh
international master livonia against
future world champion tigran petrossian
uh very nicely done uh i would like to
thank barbara mcmahon of margo pink
alessandro ligobello paul hinomund and
alan lavrish for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing uh the
coverage uh of the
uh of your suggestions basically as this
was also a suggestion and checking up on
whatever else happens in the chess world
uh so thank you all i will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day